وقفتنا الثانيه مع مراسله صباح العربيه
هذه المره من تونس مع احلام العبدلي
وانجاز تحصده المراه التونسيه عن علاج من
سم الافاعي احلام صباح الخير
شو احوالك كيف
الانوار كيف تعالجونا
صباح الانوار لكل مشاهدي صباح العربي
وبفضل علمها
تحصلات على الميداليه الذهبيه في جناب
واعلى وسام في قد يناله المختصون في الطب
في سويسرا الدكتوره اريج تمكنت من تطوير
دواء
هو عباره عن بروتين من ماذا من سم الافعى
الافعى التي طالما كانت تخيفنا وهي رمز
ربما لاشياء شريره او ما الى ذلك تحولها
الدكتوره اريج مسعدي واطباء واخرون في
اختصاصات اخرى ايضا لكن اليوم نتكلم عن
دكتوره اريج مسعدي الى دواء دواء للعيون
وتستخرج من سم الافعى بروتين يمكن من علاج
عديد الامراض التي مصابين بها مرضى السكري
او الذين يصابون باضطراب في الرؤيه وتشويش
فوضى في شبكات العين
ومفاجاه اخرى ان هذا الدواء ايضا الذي هو
عباره عن بروتين مشتق من سم افاعي توجد في
الجنوب التونسي وفي تونس عموما بامكانه ان
يعالج ايضا اورام سرطانيه بعد مزيد من
الابحاث كما لا مش لازم ننسى انه رمز
الصيدلي هو عباره عن الكاس والثعبان يعني
طيب خلينا ننتقل لموضوعنا الثاني بنحكي عن
امطار خير ويعني تفاؤل خصوصا بعد الجفاف
صحيح والفرحه العامه اجتاحت الامطار تفضلي
نعم
بجو ايجابي كبير جدا جدا استقبلت تونسيون
الامطار التي هطلت وما زالت تتهاطل وهذا
الطقس الشتوي الذي ياتي في الربيع في شهر
مايو كما كما يلقبونه التونسيون يستبشرون
كثيرا بعد موجه جفاف وجفاف كبيره جدا تهدد
الموسم الحساد تهدم الموسم الزراعي وتهدد
كامل التوازن المناخي في تونس المطر تهطل
التونسيون مستبشرون والادعيه تتواصل
وتتكاثر بان تتواصل هذه الامطار الى ان
تروي الارض وعطشها بعد اشهر من الجفاف
ودرجات الحراره القياسيه والتي تم تسجيلها
من قبل المعهد الوطني للرصد الجوي خارج
الفصول المعتاده لها وانا متفائل انه
اليوم يوم خير بالنسبه لك يا احلام
العبدلي بعيشك شكرا جزيلا
وصباحك خير ان شاء الله
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات